thương tâm dự báo khi thượng thị bán cúp ra, đã theo gió hiện thương Edinô từ đầu năm
và từ giữa thật thương đã gửi thông tin tạnh báo bán đầu tới các bộ ngành và các địa
phương để chủ động xây dân tịch bản ứng phó. Các bản tin dự báo gần đây cho thấy
Wicker xuất hiện Edinô rất mạnh năng tăng dành. Nếu trong bản tin thẳng thương,
sát xuất Edinô rất mạnh tri ở mức 20% thì đến thăng năm 2018, và hiện nay đã đã sáo
mươi tới 6%. Zimin này cho thấy hả năng xuất hiện Edinô rất mạnh là khá lớn,
con đổ tức đường đật năng à gịnh thu chăm bây lâm, hành hủ chăm bây sấu và tâm chỉ có thể mạnh hơn.
Ông mai bán khi mạnh giám lốc trung tâm dự báo khi tự tì bán cúp ra,
cho nên nếu thị bản Edinô rất mạnh sử ra, Việt Nam có quý cơ đối mặt bấy đàn dịch cao hơn
chung bình dầu năm, số đật khóc phí lạnh giám và lượng bưa thiếu của trên dễn dầu
đặc biệt tại Trung Bộ, Tây quyền và đam bộ.
Dự báo cho các thăng quyết năm hành hình thục cho 20 xấu, dự đổ chung bình cản lưỡ khó thể cao hơn
tự bình dầu năm, tự khóc phí lâm, tự bối 1,5 xe, sẽ đoàn thắng 1 tự bối 2, có nơi cao hơn từ 1 đến 2 đồ xe,
bắt bộ và chúng bộ được nhật liền có thằng năng xuất hiện nhiều đất nắng lắm thu bình thường.
Tham chỉ khi dần các giá trị nhật độ vật lix sử.
Trong khi đó, lượng bưa trị nhiều khu vật có thể tự bộ tự 2 bây lâm, tự 1,5 xam,
gió dẻ nhất tại dưới hành năng chúng bộ, Tây quyền và đam bộ.
Lâm rất tắt quyết cơ hạn hắn, kéo nước và sâm dập bằng cho các thăng quyết năm hành năng xuất hành năng.
Bọn đầu năm hành năng xuất hành năng xuất hành năng.